actually before moving on the next
problem sometimes at the end of a video
I really rush it just because I have
that silly YouTube 10-minute deadline
and so and I want you to really
understand this point here of why I
picked the negative 2 and the positive 3
because let me see let me erase some of
this and kind of show you what my
thought process was so if I so I'm using
the paintbrush to let me just let me
just blank it all out so if I just blank
that out and I could actually blank this
out I'm just blanking everything out
right I could have just erased
everything
but anyway so let's say okay so the
possible terms again once again where 0
plus or minus 2 and 5 plus or minus 3
and I want to show you why I picked the
lowest value here and the highest value
here so let me graph those points that's
my y-axis this is my x-axis and so let's
see first I have the point 0 comma plus
2 or minus 2 so this is let's call this
this is this is 0 2 this is 0 minus 2 0
minus 2 and then we have 5 let's say
this is 5 out here 5 and so this would
be let's say this is 3 up here so let's
say this is 5 positive 3 5 3 and then 5
negative 3 will be someplace right now
just not scaled up I have to squeeze at
the bottom and you get the point 5 minus
3 so there's a bunch of lines that could
connect these this whole set of points
right you have I'm gonna do them in
different colors you have this line you
have this line
you have this line and then you have
this line
well we immediately we want the highest
possible slope and you could probably
just inspect it and say well that's the
highest possible slope is the one that
moves up the steepest so it'll be this
line and you know the this line and this
line are negative slope so that's not a
high slope and the way I did it
intuitively I said well in order to have
a high slope I want as high a change in
Y as possible I wanted to maximize I
want to maximize that my change in Y
this is let me switch colors I wanted to
maximize my change in Y change in Y
given my change in X and that's why I
picked the lowest Y and the highest Y if
I wanted the lowest possible slope I
would have picked positive 2 and
negative 3 right hopefully that makes a
little bit more sense see let's do
problem number 18 18 Esther drove to
work in the morning at an average speed
of 45 miles per hour 45 miles per hours
how fast Esther drove she returned home
so this is to work to work she returned
home in the evening along the same route
and average 30 miles per hour the 30
miles per hour maybe there was more
traffic from work from work if Esther
spent a total of one hour commuting to
and from work it's a 1 hour total one
hour total how many miles did Esther
drive to work in the morning how many
miles did you drive so this is a simple
distance is equal to rate times time
distance is equal to rate times time
problem but it's a little fancy it's a
little confusing so let's just say that
D is the distance to work right let's
say DS this is work in the middle to
solve for D right so if D this D is the
distance to work
how far did if we just good that you go
in the morning so in the morning we have
the distance she went in the morning is
gonna be equal to 45 miles per hour
that's the rate right that's the rate 45
miles per hour times the time so let's
just call that times T right that's how
long that's what she did in the morning
she went 45 miles an hour times however
long it took her then in the afternoon
she's gonna go the same distance right
she was the same distance this time she
went 30 miles per hour 30 miles per hour
and how long did it take her well this
is the interesting thing
it took her a total of one hour to go to
work and back from work so if it took
her if it took her T if it let's say if
it took her T hours in the morning then
it took her 1 minus T hours 1 minus T
actually let's do it in minutes let's
assume T is in minutes so T is minutes
so then 1 hour is 60 right 60 minus T
minutes I don't know I actually have to
stay with hours cuz these are all miles
per hour so forgive me forgive me 1
minus T right does that make sense this
one I think will make sense to you 45
miles per hour times however many hours
she traveled it tells you how many miles
she went this time you have her speed 30
miles per hour times the time she
traveled well the time she traveled in
the afternoon is gonna be 1 hour -
whatever she traveled in the morning
right because when you when you combined
in the morning and afternoon she
traveled for a total of 1 hour so if she
for example if she took if she took 15
minutes to go in the morning then that
means it took her 45 minutes to come
back in the afternoon hopefully that
makes sense but these are the same DS
right so let we could set them equal to
each other so we could say 45 times T is
equal to 30 times 1 minus T let me say
45 T
is equal to 30 - 30 t and then we can
add 30 to both sides and you get 75 T is
equal to 30 then we get T is equal to 30
over 75 hours and if we divide the top
and the bottom by 5 we get 6 over when 5
goes into this how many times it goes
into actually yeah nobody divided by 5 5
goes into C 10:15 right I could divide
by a better number than than 5 actually
I could divide the top and the bottom by
15 and you get 2 over 5 right or just
take this and divided by the top and
bottom by 3 you get 2/5 so time is equal
to 2/5 hours and 2/5 hours that's what
24 minutes roughly right so the time is
2/5 hours so we go back to the distance
so distance is that's and that remember
T is how how long it took her in the
morning in the afternoon it's gonna be 1
minus this so in the afternoon it took
her 1 minus this would be 3/5 hours but
let's just go backward the question is
how many miles does she go to and from
works and that's D well D is 45 times T
T is 2/5 45 times 2/5 45 times 2/5 is d
well we can come to 9 cancelled that so
it comes 818 I mean 9 times 2 is 18 so d
is equal to 18 miles and we are done our
second SAT section I hope I didn't
confuse you too much see you soon